sometimes
[Music]
internally
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
laughs
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
check check check check check check
check
all right everyone we're getting started
you can
make a way over to the seats
um we also freed up some in the front
row over here
so
somebody wants an excellent seat
yeah got four over here
all right we've got two two three more
over here
if anybody wants to see it
all right
um hi everyone like
thanks for coming out tonight
um I'm Andrew Warner I'm the producer
for the long Now talks at the interval
and your host for this evening
[Applause]
um thanks for coming out and then a big
thank you to the live stream as well
um who lives in the sky over there you
have to trust me on that one
um this is your reminder to turn off
your cell phones or make them silent
psychedelics and other mind-altering
substances are among our oldest
continually used Technologies with
evidence of you stretching back at least
5 000 years
today they remain hotly contested and
are wildly popular despite a 50-year War
on Drugs that's done nothing to mitigate
that
um here to help us look at that past
explain the present and reveal possible
Futures is Ismail Ali welcome Ismail
[Applause]
hello
everyone can hear me okay
good we did like six sound checks so I
would certainly hope so
so before I get started talking I would
love to invite everyone to take a breath
with me
so if you're open and it's possible I
might
suggest that we
close our eyes
and if you feel comfortable and you can
couldn't put your feet on the ground
you know
maybe take a brief moment to settle
into your body
it's the middle of the week many of us
have had long days
maybe some of us have had to travel to
be here
so I just want to invite everyone for
just a moment
to drop into yourself
foreign
jump into the energy of the field
created by all of our presence
and just drop into the moment
the moment that we're in right now
together
a moment that may never be recreated
not even for the next 10 000 years
thank you feel free to start bringing
yourself back
good evening everyone
how y'all doing
yeah all right love this energy um
wow
um thank you so much uh Andrew for the
invitation
uh this was kind of born out of a
conversation that uh Andrew and I and a
few others had a few a couple of months
ago about our origin stories and about
like where we came from how we got to be
where we are today I'll share a bit
about my words and story as we start but
I just want to appreciate the Arc of new
friends and the opportunity to have
conversations like these
um in rooms full of amazing people like
this I feel very grateful for that
I want to appreciate the long now
Foundation this is my first time here at
the interval
um and it was really cool because I had
heard about the long nap Foundation
before but once this was announced I had
like dozens of people talking like oh my
God it's so cool that you're doing this
talk and I'm also really excited because
I love doing talks in person there's
been so much over zoom over the last
while it's really really exciting
um so yeah thank you all for showing up
IRL here and thank you to those that are
here digitally or there digitally really
appreciate that
um and I guess I should say Happy
Valentine's Day
um this is clearly the most romantic
thing you could be doing uh on a win you
know Tuesday evening so really
appreciate uh your willingness to come
through and talk about psyched dogs with
me
um
so
my name is Ali
um and I'm currently the director of
policy and advocacy at the
multidisciplinary association for
psychedelic studies also known as Maps
today I'll share a little bit of
introduction a little bit my origin
story I'll talk a little bit about Maps
and then I'll give some context on um
history like my version of history and
what I would say is a more complete
version of history with respect to how
exactly we got here history of
psychedelics which Andrew kind of
briefly shared in the introduction
I'll share a little bit today about
where we're at politically a lot of my
job has to do with engaging with the
political system and the regulatory
system so I'll give a bit of an overview
of that and then I'll close with just a
few thoughts about
um what I think we could do or where we
might be going
um and then there'll be time for Q a at
the end and uh I love all the questions
um I like to think of myself as highly
interruptible but because of the tech
setup we're going to hold questions to
the end
um so just letting you know that right
now
so what exactly is going on here so I
was born in Fresno California
uh I was raised by two parents who were
immigrants my mother was born in Cali
Colombia my dad was born in Delhi India
but raised in kanachi they left their
respective countries to escape political
and economic turmoil uh and then a few
years later some years later 911
happened and that really changed
everything for me as a young Muslim
raised in the Central Valley of
California some of you may have spent
some time there people also call it the
Bible Belt of the West Coast
um it was really interesting to
immediately be kind of thrust I like to
stay politically socialized without my
consent as a person who was a Muslim kid
a multi-racial multi Multicultural and
just like realizing that there was this
larger Arc of history that was happening
around me and I was kind of forced into
that understanding at a really young age
um and it kind of made me really
depressed it made it really difficult I
was full of angst uh full of uh kind of
resistance uh to the status quo as it
kind of was imposed on me
um until I wasn't I uh discovered
psychedelics
as a teenager
um and was immediately welcomed into
Rave culture uh and I like to say that
that angst turned into curiosity and
that was really a huge shift that was
over 15 years ago and that ship from
angst to curiosity is a big part of what
I think keeps me kind of going even in
the midst of a constant barrage of uh
really depressing and continually
existentially confronting news that I
feel like we're all getting all the time
um that was my late teens I uh when I
was uh 20 years old I ran into my uh
family member in Columbia visiting I
hadn't seen them for a long time and I
was like
know anything about OSD you know you
know acid I threw parties
um because I was throwing Raves you know
as a young person and kind of
undergrounds and that was when I learned
that I had family members that had been
working in the realm of bridging
transpersonal Psychotherapy and
psychedelic Shamanism for literally
decades so I'm here telling my family
member have you heard of LSD and they're
like you have no idea so I was taken
they took me to the desert so I spent
went out you know when I was in my early
20s I spent some time in wirikuta and
San Jose Potosi it was kind of my first
contact with the more spiritual practice
I had been seeking that but I didn't
really know what it was I was seeking
until I started to make contact with
some of these older traditions
um so a few years later I went to law
school ended up working uh for the ACLU
of Northern California and eventually
for maps uh which I really love and I'll
talk a little bit more about them but
this is actually me at the conference in
um really excited apparently about this
concept of fake news
um and over the last few years I've kind
of moved into a place where I get to I
feel very grateful before I get to be in
conversation as an educator about
psychedelics to the public uh to
professionals like lawyers and doctors
but also to legislators I spent a lot of
time now speaking with people who are
elected both in the United States and as
well as around the world around like
what psychedelics are how they work and
in many cases as I can go into more
later
um how to talk about them without
sounding crazy um and there are a lot of
people who are interested and who are
kind of interested in the closet but
what's happening is that the barrier to
entry to talking about psychedelics is
starting to reduce so it's getting
easier and easier to talk about that
publicly and I'll go more into that
so really briefly I'll talk a little bit
about Maps
um I think a lot of you may be familiar
but Maps is a nonprofit that was founded
at 01986.
um I don't know how what the what the
naming convention is when you add the
zero but I thought I'd be cute
um and uh I've been sponsoring
psychedelic assisted therapy trials for
the last 20 25 years
um and we educate people to benefit from
the careful uses of psychedelics
psychedelics and marijuana so we're
really an educational research
organization
um that is really looking toward kind of
I think for a long time the frame and
this is true of a lot of drug policy the
frame was how do we dismantle the
current system and what I've realized in
a lot of what Maps works on and what I
work on with my colleagues that are here
in other places is the kind of the
building of the alternative
infrastructure like what is it that we
go to we can kind of dismantle the War
on Drugs we can end mass incarceration
we can do all those things and I really
believe that we're slowly slowly slowly
but surely moving toward that
um but there will need to be systems
that catch people
um because right now the only ones we
have are the ones that are broken or
fundamentally working exactly how
they're supposed to depending on your
frame
um so Maps is the sole owner of the
mouse polar benefit corporation which is
founded it in toe any 14.
and that organization works for drug
development so it's essentially a small
Pharma company that's working toward
therapy education and creating FDA
approved drugs so right now our Flagship
project which I'm sure a lot of people
are familiar with is taking MDMA
through the FDA approval process uh and
I'm happy to announce that we just we
recently announced we just completed our
second phase three trial which means
we're now in the last leg before
submitting the um NDA to the FDA
hopefully this year
um I'm feeling really excited about that
I'll just walk through these really
quickly Maps has seven principles that
we operate on I'm not going to go into
them right now I'm happy to go into them
in the Q a if desired but I just wanted
to to frame them because I think that
they kind of help give a sense of the
um uh conceptual Arc and the type of
work that we're trying to bring to the
world healing for all
prioritizing public benefit open science
open books I love this one because I'm
all about how do we make things
accessible to the public that are
usually esoteric unavailable knowledge
set the setting some of you are familiar
with the concept of set and setting but
we kind of believe in the city of
setting the setting like we're going to
be create we're actually building out
the setting in which uh political change
prohibition will change and so on as we
speak so there's this idea that we
actually have some agency there
um this idea of Consciousness without
criminalization I'll talk a little bit
of criminalization and decriminalization
specifically later on
um this idea of being the bridge we have
a really wide uh kind of a white
umbrella under which uh we work and you
can imagine and as you've seen more and
more
um politically and I think Andrew and I
will talk about this a bit in the Q a
the type of people that are attracted to
psychedelics it's not really just one
type of person anymore there was that
concept for a long time but that's
really not true
um I think it never was but there's this
idea that there's a particular type of
person who like looks a certain way and
maybe smells a certain way that's into
them but that's really starting to
change
um and the final one is my favorite
which is seeing past the Paradox which
is just a general uh concept when we
approach these big complex questions
that relate to criminalization in our
future and where we go from here
um so I'm going to talk a little bit
about history everyone good so far
I'm talking a bit fast I have a lot to
cover I want to give space okay
um
so
I want to talk a little bit about
history because
um a lot of people when they think about
drug policy reform and when they're
thinking about these Concepts they tend
to start that clock in about 1971 when
the control Substances Act was passed
which is a perfectly valid spot but I
want to zoom way back and just give a
few kind of Milestones before we even
get to 1970. uh just a frame like my
understanding of how I think about
um psychedelics and the current kind of
current status of where we're at
um
so I think a lot of people know this
psychedelics have been used
psychological plants and fungi haven't
you start history there's evidence going
back literally thousands and thousands
of years and I put this list up healing
cultural communitarian sacramental
political and other purposes because I
think the narrative today is really
dominated by this conversation about
medicalization partially because of the
advocacy that we've done but also
because it's really more politically
viable to say oh we're working in this
realm of medicalization of Science of
research and so on so there's kind of
this not only that but there's also this
um extreme need and Desperation around
Mental Health Solutions so those two
things combined mean that the primary
narrative right now is about health care
and um and medicine but I name all those
things because I think it's really
important to remember that as we think
about moving back into a paradigm where
psychedelics are integrated or
reintegrated or properly integrated in
society depending on how you want to
frame it
um that they're done in a way that does
not only include uh medicine as a
concept let me get more into that so
these are just some photos of these like
super our old kind of examples of
psychedelics and art somewhere so we've
got ellucius we've got San Pedro we've
got really examples and multiple if not
every continent over the course of a few
thousand years so there's a lot of good
evidence for that and I think that's one
of the conversations that's been
re-emerging which is what does it mean
to be bringing these ancient practices
that in many ways never disappeared into
the Paradigm that we live in today
um so this is the fun part it's not fun
um colonization is Legacy so a lot of
people start the history of psychedelics
and drug policy as I mentioned drug
reform excuse me um criminalization 50
years ago but I actually bring it back
to the 1500s there's evidence that when
colonizers entered what they call the
new world uh that they witnessed the
practice of ingestion of psychoactive
plants peyote and mushrooms among others
and immediately saw that as a demonic
practice so I actually think that the
groundwork for what we now know today as
the War on Drugs started 500 years ago
and that was like kind of the beginning
of the
um kind of homogenization the way that
kind of culture specifically was kind of
fit through a particular lens and we see
that with the cultural and literal
genocide of indigenous people throughout
history that in many ways is also very
tied to the the
genocide of culture itself of like the
actual communitarian practices that
we're used to maintain cohesion
um
uh and actually before yeah before I get
to the next one actually that you you
know you can bring that up back up to
the 1800s or so you've got a few hundred
years there where practices went highly
underground and it was really like the
mid-1800s or yeah mid-1800s 1880s or so
that you see the beginning of what we
kind of see of the current Global Drug
control scheme in the late 1800s a lot
of the world superpowers were making a
lot of money off of selling drugs they
were selling all kinds of drugs they're
selling tea and they were selling coffee
but they're also selling opium and a lot
of other things over the course of many
years so when the U.S yes that's us
um started pressuring some of these
governments the Dutch government the UK
government and so on in the late 1800s
to start criminalizing substances they
actually there was actually a lot of
resistance
um and from about 1800s to really after
World War II there was quite a bit of
resistance from the globe but a lot of
people don't know this of the desire to
criminalize in the first place because
they're like why would we criminalize
something if we're making Bank off of it
um and that started to change as the
kind of global superpower shifted and
over the course of World War One and
World War II and suddenly the US which
had banned opium in the 1800s because of
all the Chinese immigrants that are
coming into the west coast to build the
railroads where suddenly was suddenly
not so much of an outlier but was
realizing that these mechanisms could be
used for social control and you see that
repeated in the 1930s with cannabis
so you've got like by the time you get
to you know the mid 1900s you've
actually got quite a few examples of
that criminalization beginning to occur
um and it was around that shift that you
see the beginning of the current Western
Medical Research on some of these
substances including LSD MDMA and
mescaline peyote Etc and some of it was
to treat mental health conditions you
have some early uh research on
alcoholism Stan Groff is really well
known for his early research in the 50s
in the Czech Republic with LSD on both
survivors of the Holocaust as well as
Nazis there was some really interesting
literature about research that was done
in the 50s in the wake of World War II
with OSD
um but a lot of that kind of information
started to really like bubble up in the
mid in the mid 1900s
um and a lot of us know a lot of those
famous names and books and so on I'm not
going to go super into that today
um
the next oh yeah so by 1951 there's over
100 articles and a lot of people maybe
aren't super aware that a lot of
research was happening really fast
people were really excited about acid
you know they really were they really
were it was like nothing else they had
seen before you know like or you know
people thought that at least so there
was a lot of um
there was just a lot of like potential
and a lot of and there's a whole Shadow
history that I'm sure a lot of people
know about that I'm not going to go into
today around using the CIA to do some
mind control I'm not going to talk about
that today that's really its own
conversation but it's worth getting into
if you don't already know
um so bringing us back up to the 1960s
so that criminalization that had started
with various tax acts and various other
kinds of restrictions begins to be
encoded into law and actually I think
California uh criminalized LSD in 67 I
want to say it was a little bit before
the control services control Substances
Act was passed so you kind of start to
see a little bit of that groundwork
being sent early on and it was really
1971 that this was encoded into law
um and then all this started to happen
scientific inquiry quashed tens of
millions this is like funny but it's
really not it's actually horrible and
it's what's been happening for the last
50 years millions of people are
incarcerated hundreds of thousands of
people are killed and I wanted to pause
here because I mentioned earlier that my
mom's family is from Colombia the reason
that they left in 1986 was because the
violence in Kali was so bad that people
would tattoo or wear their blood type on
them because there were so many people
who had to get sent to the hospital
um and I want to say that because it's
really important it is important to talk
about incarceration and so on but I
really like to remind people that the
War on Drugs is a global effort and the
U.S really LED it and there's really
good literature about how the US
pressured the rest of the world in the
U.N and so on to do that but I just want
to mention that like the cost of our
cheap access to Great drugs here in
California like really does have a
violent tale like a lot of these drugs
that are manufactured in other parts of
the world actually have an impact on
people and that has caused a lot of
Challenge and literal violence in many
places over the course of history and
currently
and of course it's really expensive we
spend a ton of money on enforcing stuff
um some people may be know this already
but the plan Colombia you know the
eradication of Coca the pesticide use in
Colombia those laws a lot of those early
laws in Colombia were written in English
by U.S lawyers when we just when we
handed them to the Colombian government
we're like this is what you're going to
do and we funded it we spent billions
and billion spend current present tense
billions and billions of dollars on
eradicating a plant that by the way
grows a lot everywhere it's just not
working
um and where are we at today drugs are
cheaper and more important than ever I'm
not going to go more into that because
I'm sure a lot of you know that know
that already but that's just some that's
that's true it's it's like if if you see
prohibition as uh an attempt to actually
quash and reduce the use of drugs then
it's completely failed if you see it as
a mechanism of social control then it's
highly effective so it's really about
the angle and I don't like to say that
War on Drugs has failed because it has
According to some metrics but it really
depends on the angle through which
you're framing it
um so actually this publisher started in
1994 not 2004 because I want to
appreciate Rick Strassman who started
doing DMT research in 1994 in Santa Fe
or uh University of New Mexico
um before and I would say a lot of
people tend to credit Dr Strassman for
the beginning of what we kind of see as
the new Rave of psychedelic research
that's occurring
um
starting in 2004 though actually uh Maps
was able to start a clinical trials
there's a whole story that goes into
that but we started in Spain and have
kind of expanded over the course of last
bunch of years and as I said we just hit
a really beautiful Milestone of
finishing the phase three trials many
years later
um and now we have clinical trials of
LSD psilocybin Ayahuasca DMT I began
ketamine and just like a bunch of
substances that also have a lot of
letters and numbers that some of which
are new some of which aren't
um and some of that is really focused
like I said earlier on the treatment
treatment of mental health conditions um
and you know we write Mind Body
illnesses because mental health itself
is a paradigm that is useful to a
certain extent and I think that once you
kind of come up to the level of well how
much of this is inside my brain versus
how much of this is a socially
constructed experience it's harder to
kind of frame it as a mental health
thing it's like starting to be maybe
this is a result of our circumstances
environment who knows or maybe some
combination of those
so far so good
okay
um so that is a decent overview and
maybe one thing I'll say before I get to
where we are now is um this idea of uh
lineages and the way that some of this
knowledge has been maintained throughout
history
um as I said earlier there you know the
beginning of their oppression from the
Catholic Church the Spanish and
Portuguese governments and other
governments in the 1500s did not
necessarily it led to
eradication and genocide and all of this
oppression but it did not fully
eliminate the practice and I think I
really want to mention that there have
been continued unbroken lineages that
have occurred throughout history and
many of which have been interrupted and
then re-re
um kind of reclaimed you could say and I
I think of myself as someone with
interrupted lineages my lineages were
interrupted by colonization and I really
worked toward reclaiming those things to
the extent that I can
um in modernity or whatever which is a
bit challenging but um there's some
really cool like deep cuts that I like
to share around these lineages I just
learned some of you might know this
already I just learned that um does
anyone here know who Claude is do people
know Claudio he's best known for a lot
of things but in particular
um turning the Enneagram are you
familiar familiar with the Enneagram
Claudia naranjo is the psychotherapist
who was really involved one of the
people was really involved in bringing
out the Enneagram into kind of modern
psychology
I just found out that Claudio this is in
the beginning of one of his books
um Claudio took a vial of LSD down to
Colombia uh in the 50s and gifted a
violet LSD to some co-fine Elders
co-fine is a tribe in Colombia that
works with yahe which is what they call
Ayahuasca but um I just had this moment
of imagining like what is it like to be
in the 50s in the jungle taking LSD from
this random you know white guy who just
showed up and is like I'll trade you
plants for this liquid you know um so
there's all this like really cool
interesting history that's occurred over
over time and I I like liking that too
um this place where we're at now of
understanding the Contemporary use of
psychedelics in a variety of different
contexts both for political and
communitarian needs reasons in addition
to Medical
um and therapeutic ones
so let's talk a little bit about where
we're at today so
um
a number of local policy changes have
occurred in the last few years I started
working at maps in
2015 2016. I had been working on drug
policy for some time before that point
but when I started working I really
thought I was going to be in this little
niche of the drug policy world I was
like okay there's all this cool stuff
happening with say conjection and
medication it's just a treatment and all
these big cannabis legalization I'm just
going to be in my little corner with
psychedelics
and then two years passed and Michael
Paul had to change her mind and a bunch
of other things happened
um and suddenly it went from being oh
maybe we can one day imagine what a
psychedelic policy reform Paradigm could
look like to catching up to a rapid
increase of the types of changes that we
were maybe hoping to see admittedly
um in uh kind of a world that didn't
really know what to do with that speed
of expansion so
um in 2020 a lot of you know this
already Oregon voters approved a measure
two measures actually measures 110 and
109 to decriminalize the personal use of
most drugs that should say most not all
actually and develop state legal access
to psilocybin treatments and regulated
centers so I was I on the equity
subcommittee of that program of the opab
organ psilocybin Advisory board up until
just recently
um and that program while being passed
in 2020 had a two-year incubation period
you could say like a pre-implementation
and I imagine that people will start
getting treated under that framework in
about
um two months is like really where we're
at officially started the beginning of
this year
um but they have to train people
um earlier just a few months ago a
similar bill passes in Colorado I really
love the bill in Colorado proposition
122 because it both decriminalized the
personal use of a number of psychedelics
as well as created a regulated system
and as someone who's really committed to
decriminalization and moving away from
the criminalization of these substances
trying to find a balance where you can
have
um freedom to grow it yourself in your
home but also a regulated system if
that's what you want
um can be really helpful and really
informative in that
um and of course since 2019 especially a
number of cities have considered drug
plus reform I have to put like kind of
policy nerd had on here real quick uh
there's a lot of confusing media that
talks about decriminalization criminal
law tends to be enforced at the state
level state and federal level cities
don't enforce them they have uh law
enforcement but the actual enforcement
of the law happens at the state level
the reason that's relevant is because a
lot of cities that have been getting a
lot of news including Oakland including
San Francisco have de-prioritized
enforcement which basically means that
the city does isn't supposed to be
spending money on enforcing laws related
to that that's not quite the same thing
as decriminalization which is what we're
going for with SB 58 in California which
is reintroduced this year as well as
other bills including the win in
Colorado that are really like taking the
activity out of the criminal code at the
state level which removes that tool from
the prosecutor to do so federal
government could still get involved if
they want but and that's a rabbit hole
maybe we can go down the Q a if we want
but basically the federal government
tends right now seeing to be relatively
wait and see about the things that are
happening which is very different from
what it was like with cannabis
um you know 20 years ago as I'm sure a
lot of you know
um and this is an exciting one for those
of us that are kind of in the research
World there have been there's been a
total freeze on federal funding for a
really long time and uh the NIH National
Institute of Health and other Federal
entities are beginning to slowly slowly
put money toward research which is a
really big deal because up until this
point most of the research has been
funded by philanthropy and a little bit
increasingly by other kinds of
investment as although that's fairly
recent
um so this year
what's going on this year
um we're hoping the MDMA assistant
therapy will be considered by the FDA
that's a really big milestone that we're
really excited about it maps and also
it's a big deal for the field because it
would kind of be the beginning of what I
anticipate and what we anticipate will
be a wave of many substances
um with multiple organizations that are
all kind of looking at what how could
they be incorporated into Healthcare is
it possible if so how
um and I do think that there will be
more substances and indications that
enter phase three trials if not this
year than very soon and um without going
too much into it there's there's three
phases with FDA so the third one is the
last one which is a good sign
um and then lastly this is something I'm
really really excited about because as
we move towards decriminalization
um one thing I like to remind people is
that without education harm reduction
and crisis response we're kind of just
like throwing a bunch of new ideas out
there with very little support some of
you may have noticed we have a rapidly
deteriorating social safety net
um so the uh adoption of Public Health
harm reduction measures is like a major
part of that and I like to think of all
of the excitement around psychedelics of
which there is a lot nowadays
um as kind of a trojan horse for other
kinds of goods sensible policies one
being unarmed crisis response for
example you have cities like Denver and
Eugene Oregon have programs that are
calling in people for mental health
crises that are not armed that are
trained in the escalation
um it's not perfect but I think that if
we funded de-escalation unarmed
de-escalation I think that we would
actually like the way especially if we
did the way that we funded cops law
enforcement I imagine that we might be
able to actually like have a different
type of intervention when things go
wrong on the street
as I hope
okay I'm gonna talk for just a few more
minutes everyone good all right this is
the last slide
um so this this last piece is about
where we go from here
um
and
first off I'll say that I'm really
excited about
um the possibility of uh passing uh SB
58 in California we'll see for those
that you were following SB 519 was
introduced by Senator Scott weiner in
well December January 2021
um and yeah right and uh that was
there's a whole Saga and what happened
with that but it was reintroduced this
year after not passing
um it's a little bit you know a little
bit simplified there's a few things that
I don't love about it like they took
ketamine out
why wouldn't you decriminalize no I mean
just just to go down the tiny rabbit
hole like if you're decriminalizing
drugs for a public health reason
the mushrooms are not the things that
are causing the overdoses people see
mushrooms and like oh this is a mushroom
it's actually imperative it's kind of
counterintuitive it's actually
imperative to decriminalize the white
powders because that's the stuff that
gets adulterated that's the stuff that
people actually have dangerous
experiences of it's kind of a sunlight
effect suddenly if the drug use has
decriminalized if assault happens or if
there's another crime another thing that
happens suddenly the people who are
using the drugs aren't afraid of their
own
um are being implicated in crime
suddenly they can say oh this thing went
wrong and I feel safe bringing that up
and actually having some some sort of
response to it right now a lot a lot of
impacts are disincent or reporting a lot
of negative impacts is disincentivized
because people can't don't feel like
they can safely talk about something
that happened while drugs were involved
um so yeah it's like funny but it's also
very serious it's completely serious
that like the overdose crisis that
there's a very very constant increasing
and adult increase in adulteration the
quality of drugs cheaper and better but
also scarier in many ways
um so just to close I
I like to think a lot and one of the
things that inspired this conversation
um
is this idea of like what would a
wholesome drug culture look like
um one thing that I can share more if
desired but that I feel really proud and
excited about is as part of the
articulation of the seleniors this
family history that I have that
um has given me so much and allowed me
to feel so clear and uh with like kind
of this Arc uh that I feel like I'm
participating along with a lot of people
here
um is the possibility of
the possibility of not having
um drug use and this process of healing
and personal growth and expansion to be
something that has to happen in the
shadows there's a lot of value in the
shadow and I encourage everybody to look
closely at yours but
but I do think that the fact that
psychedelics have been and Other Drugs
have been so stigmatized over such a
long time means that it's really hard to
have mature conversations about them and
it's very easy to like fall into the
realm of tropes and
um I get that all the time in my work
people are constantly like in that kind
of Trope stigma world
and it's actually quite radical to like
to um
demystify some of that and make room for
these other ways of being that involve
family related work that involve
wholesomeness and wholeness
um I like to think of it as doing drugs
with dignity and it is it possible to
have a relationship with these
substances that actually allows me to be
a dignified person
um maybe I'll close with a little
anecdote because I think it it gets to
what I'm what I'm hoping to see in
addition to uh custom LSD Stores
um it would be I I started working
um my mother passed away 10 years ago uh
and she had cancer for 12 years and
um it was actually shortly after that
that I left Fresno to come up here to
the Bay Area to start Law School and I
feel one of the things that occurred in
the wake of her passing was uh like it
has happened to many families is like
this rupture she was really like the
social major center of our kind of
collective social experience
and
um we experienced a lot of grief as a
result of her passing
and in 2015 uh partially because of
these relational connections and this
growth my family started drinking
Ayahuasca together my grandmother and my
aunts my cousins my brothers three
generations we've not been doing that
every few years
um and I bring this up uh even though I
could make a lot of like kind of
off-color jokes I'm sure because
the experience of working with my family
in that context has really showed me
that this idea of psychedelics as this
wholesome
um
vitamin nutrient as part of our
experience something that's been part of
our experience of Consciousness and
collectivism and Community for so many
years is that it's actually possible to
bring that back and to make it something
that's not just
I was gonna say not scary I don't think
it's possible to make psychedelics not
scary there's always gonna be a little
bit of thought but certainly something
that doesn't have to be so uh
stigmatized so pushed out to the margins
uh something that's so difficult to
actually have a mature conversation
about because one of the things that
I've noticed talking about psychedelics
with so many people is that ultimately a
lot of conversations we have about
psychedelics are not about psychedelics
they're about grief they're about trauma
they're about expansion they're about
Community they're about connection
they're about all the things that
psychedelics might help reveal but um
the second Oak is really just the tool
just a catalyst and I like to remind
people that this idea of this
post-prohibition world that we're trying
to create has a lot more of all those
things hopefully more psychedelics too
but certainly also more kind of contact
with that essential aspect of ourself
um so I just talked a lot I'll pause
that for now thank you so much for
listening to me appreciate it
come on
now check chat all right
um
we're gonna do some questions I'm gonna
ask a few questions myself first
um but then we have a mic that's going
around Julianne right there has it if
you raise your hands Julianne will come
find you hopefully although we probably
won't be able to get to all the
questions
um and just make sure to hold the
microphone
um close so that
um people can hear your question Forever
on the internet
um
and
I think that's it thank you
um so
this talk came from a conversation where
we were you know this idea of doing this
talk where we were talking about the
difficulty of
um studying something or working with
something
um that uh in history maybe didn't fit
into a nice category so if you try to
study religion for example
um if you go back in time and look at
early religion you find that it often
was simultaneously religious or
celebratory or economic
um and or artistic and the sort of
category of religion itself fails and um
psychedelics seems to sort of have that
same property
um what's the experience of you know
working with this thing that
simultaneously operates on all of these
contacts yet having to put it in this
very specific legal category of like FDA
approved substance
yeah thanks for the question one thing
that I didn't get into
um is like these different legal
categories and how right now in the
United States you really've got two
options either it's medicine FDA
approved through the proper channels or
it's a sacrament
and um there's a whole rabbit hole about
religious and spiritually so we could go
down but the important thing is that
right now either you're in kind of
religious freedom territory and for
those of you that don't know the history
of the United States that basically
means government get your hands off of
me religion the religious freedom the
kind of sacramental spiritual use is
like
we're over here doing our own thing or
there's a treated indication and there's
a thing that it treats and it's a
treatment
so it is interesting to watch like I
kind of saying at the beginning
um psychedelics which as you said have
this like super wide history and present
um of kind of modalities and Frameworks
of use trying to fit into that
um box and maybe one I'll just like one
simple thing is like right now if you
have a church or if you're working in
the realm of um kind of sacramental use
you better not be making medical claims
you can't be saying oh this spiritual
practice is going to cure XYZ
and if you're in medicine there's a lot
of skepticism about talking about
spirituality less and less you know
that's changing you're seeing a lot more
integrated medicine start to kind of see
those overlaps
um but it does kind of require this kind
of siloing
and part of the reason I'm glad you
asked that and why I always talk about
those different uses is because if
you're just looking at the media or
you're just looking at kind of what's up
you wouldn't know that those boundaries
are way blurrier than
we kind of have to pretend like they are
um so there is kind of this like
yeah they can be used as medicine and
they are called that and utilized that
way
um but it's it starts to get fuzzy when
you're like oh
what am I trying to treat like what are
and that's what I was saying earlier on
mental health conditions like what do we
call like what is depression what are
these things what are these phenomena
that we experience through the lens of
like the DSM-5 or whatever you know
um cool thanks
um so you you've been going the medical
route but like
the American Medical system sort of like
notoriously flawed like often just
straight up horrifying
um you know like why why go the
pharmaceutical route
um when there's so much like big
business big money and sort of like
scary entities that going on there yeah
it's a really good question I I'll share
first a little bit of like the way that
Rick Dublin the founder Maps frames it
which is uh this idea because keep in
mind that this organization was started
in uh 0901986
um which means that a lot of those
opportunities like that we kind of see
now just didn't exist at that time and
you can kind of see the arc with
um cannabis where the beginning of
understanding it as a medical tool
before even prop 215 with in 96 here in
California you know I'm sure a lot of
you are familiar with that history but
even before that you had this idea like
oh cannabis might be a medicine you know
for AIDS wasting syndrome or for cancer
these different indications
um
and now like even though there's a lot
of flaws that I can point out with the
Cannabis industry there is this level
that like oh normalizing it as a
treatment maybe is a way to get into
people's heads that oh maybe it's not as
scary as a lot of other as that's kind
of being treated
um so that's the one I would say
strategic justification
but your point is well taken and I agree
that the and especially now we can
really feel I'm sure folks that are
tracking like you can really see how
coming closer and closer to kind of the
formal Healthcare System is coming at
this really scary cost because suddenly
we have to deal with insurance suddenly
we have to deal with all of these kind
of regulatory Frameworks and all of
these economic realities that kind of
have created the monster that is
American Healthcare right now and I
tried to remember it's sometimes easier
than others but try to remind people
that in order to move toward really
Equitable access even through a purely
medical mental health frame
um we actually like have a lot of other
reform that needs to happen whether it's
with the insurance system or the other
pieces
um and just one interesting anecdote is
we're working simultaneously in the US
and Europe and it's really interesting
to see how in Europe because a lot of
countries uh have their kind of internal
uh Healthcare Systems uh the kind of
logic or the um the calculus that's used
to determine whether or not a drug
should be approved is quite different
because there's this whole aspect that's
sort of taken off the table in certain
places in Europe where you actually
they're actually they actually are
thinking about affordability in a way
that you don't really see American
Health Systems do it so I I guess I
guess the tldr of that whole thing is
there's
um there are a lot of big costs and
risks of engaging with the U.S
Healthcare System I feel
hyper aware of the way that that limits
accessibility and the way that I
personally balance that on like the
policy advocacy side is by making sure
that we have other points of access
whether it's sacramental use
decriminalized personal use and home
grow regulated they'll use that side of
Medicine
I think that I'm a person that believes
in a lot of on-ramps and a lot of
off-ramps I think healthcare is one
really important place to go because a
lot of people will not go to underground
practitioners they need to go to a
psychiatrist they will not
and a lot of people I know that um
you know don't want to go to an
underground practitioner like really
want to go to a psychiatrist or vice
versa who people who really will never
go to a psychiatrist will only go to
undergrad practitioners so I really see
it as one element in the toolkit
um with all the big caveats and risk
that you're describing yeah okay
thanks
um we've been talking about the medical
route but there is this whole religious
route you mentioned
um so you know our new conservative
Supreme Court has been using the
religious freedom exemption to like roll
back some civil liberties
um is there you know with this sort of
new framing of
um religious freedom that we're probably
going to see over the next few years
does that change anything in this space
this is a very interesting question
um because this is a very classic
strange bedfellows kind of situation
where the increased protections for
religious practice in the U.S that have
by the Supreme Court and others
overwhelmingly been used to benefit
reactionary
uh religious practice
have also been the same arguments that
have been used to permit
sacramental use of antigens
there's a major overlap in those two
arguments
so what that means is that
there's a I don't wanna
I don't want to call it a deal with the
devil but there's certainly this level
where
there's certainly this level where
um because of the increased
permissiveness that exists under the
religious freedom restoration Act and
the current kind of constitutional
religious freedom perspective
protections as they exist
um there's this kind of thing where it's
like oh every time more ground is given
there there's actually potentially a
stronger argument to permit sacramental
use of entheogenic or practitioners who
are working with entheogens in
sacramental context to also use those
same benefits
I work very closely with with some
Churches
um some religious groups who work with
entheogens and it's definitely an area
that unlike medical use which has like a
really big regulatory framework that
we're already kind of plugging into
the religious freedom world is
it's a little bit harder to Define and
because it because the idea is like oh
get the government out of it it means
that there's a lot more need for
self-regulation Best Practices ethics
within those communities which is very
different kind of from a positionality
angle
um
and
I guess just to end the answer this I'll
say I wish that there were other
mechanisms for mechanisms for protection
of these practices but right now because
it requires making exemptions to
generally applicable laws which is what
we're seeing in these other places
because you get these churches you know
the more reactionary ones are getting
exemptions like civil rights laws like
generally applicable laws or like wait a
minute that's not cool but then suddenly
we won an exception from the Controlled
Substances Act so our drug use isn't
considered drug use it's considered a
different thing
um and it's one of those places where
it's a legal argument framework and we
have to figure out like how how close to
the fire willing to get recognizing that
it's enhancing and engaging with these
systems these decisions as you described
amazing all right I got one more and
then I'll let y'all ask questions
um what about the Dark Side of
psychedelics so you know there's
um historical reports of Viking
Berserkers eating the mushrooms before
their raids and go kill a bunch of
people but also in modern times you have
MK Ultra military applications and then
the most recent you know sort of like
right-wing acid head pandemic sort of
horror thing
um
uh you know well psychedelics free our
minds
um
I was at a conference in the fall and
I felt like such a wet blanket because
one of the questions that came up was
something like this they were like
one of the when are the elected reps one
of these old white guys gonna start
doing psychedelics
why why aren't our representatives in
Congress doing psychedelics and you know
if you have to like yeah yeah we got to
do that and then I had to be the person
to take them I can be like
everyone who you're scared of has been
doing psychedelics for a long time
I really can they fear our minds I
certainly feel like they've done a lot
for me personally
um even though I'm really careful not to
be an evangelist around that but
um not necessarily I'm a person that
believes that psychedelics tend to be
highly attuned to their environment
um I'm not really sure if there's like
an inherent moral value in the molecules
um I think that there's an argument for
it depending on the context and
tradition and so on but generally
speaking I think that um psychedelics
can and R have been throughout history
utilized in a number of different
contexts not just the fun ones that we
were talking about but also some
um more impressive and negative ones and
I do feel like that it's context
specific and I think that that's why I
feel so committed to figuring out how do
we design this post-prohibition
environment to make it possible for that
kind of
pro-social even that has a value frame
um
use liberatory you could say used to be
possible
um and I think one of the risks of uh
kind of an unfettered
everything goes kind of framework is
that you allow people to abuse and
misuse that the power that comes with
access to psychedelics and the mind
states that um kind of are brought with
them to use them in a way that's that's
more harmful so I do I I try not to have
like
I try not to be too starry-eyed about it
because I do feel like that that context
really matters
um and I do have concerns that without
some groundwork cultural social
and so on
um that they they can and will be used
to harm people
um as they currently are in some in some
context so
will they fear in mind I hope so but I
don't think it's that simple and I think
we actually need to be quite diligent
um about
yeah what it means for them to be coming
into the world stage in such a visible
way they've always been there but in
such a visible way in a way that they're
there now cool all right got a question
over here
I kind of want to follow this thread you
all just started um I'm curious how you
think it'll really affect us in the
American culture I feel like we're kind
of in a suicidal moment here in the
United States all kinds of ways we're
killing ourselves and if it's a value
neutral molecule
and it's not the 60s and we're going for
a more integrated wholesome fruition
here how do you see that playing out
such a good question
um I'm encouraged by some of the
research that's been coming out around
nature relatedness and openness I do
think that because the story of
psychedelics in the west has to do with
hippies in some ways I think that
actually kind of helps that cultural
context in the way that that association
means that many people who come into
contact with psychedelics
overwhelmingly whom are not doing in a
legal context right are getting it with
that cultural context and that cultural
history
so in some ways it's kind of like a
self-fulfilling thing where the story
and narrative around psychedelics as
things open your mind like tend to have
the effects of opening people's minds
um just like de facto in the wild
um of course that's not always true but
so that's kind of the optimistic
perspective
um I think to your point about like the
general suicidality of American culture
like that's a deep
question that I think
um to me intersects a lot with kind of
the hyper individualism of how we think
about mental health in the first place
and one of the concerns to kind of
Andrew your earlier point about
incorporating something into Healthcare
without giving all the rest of the
context is that we kind of treat
psychedelics as the Silver Bullet as
just another thing to consume
so you do see in some even amazing
celebratory party cultures you still see
that
and
um I do worry that uh psychedelics are
not as strong as in that sense in the
culture in in
um I'm not as not strong enough to
really break out of that and I don't
know
um I was at a conference some years ago
and
um someone asked a question about
psychedelics and capitalism what happens
when they intersect
and um someone brought up the anecdote
that uh in the 80s as you had the rise
of televangelism
a lot of people thought that
Christianity was stronger than
capitalism and they were like it'll
never get subsumed into that so I don't
I try not to be like too hyper
optimistic about the fact that
psychedelics whether or not they're
neutral however they fit like can and
will be incorporated into the monster of
consumption that defines so many of our
lives and that is a concern that I have
which is also why I fight for homegirl
because if you care if you can home grow
then a lot of that changes but again
it's a longer conversation but that
shadow is very real
got one over there I was wondering if
you could tell us a little bit more
about the state law the California state
law and particularly why ketamine got
taken out of it I find that interesting
because
Kaiser will give it to me
um and I get ads for it on Facebook all
the time
um let's talk about ketamine
um so we were talking about this before
because people are like wait a minute
how am I getting Facebook ads like how
what in what pair day
um
I'll talk about the bill first answer
question then maybe I'll get on subox
after that
um so uh shortly after Oregon voters
passed uh measures 109 110 in November
2020.
um Senator Scott weiner tweeted actually
uh I want to pass a bill about
psychedelics and it was funny because no
one it was kind of you know we're all
like oh my God there's gonna be a bill
in California let's do this and there
was a coalition that was brought
together in early 2021
the original language of the bill uh
decriminalized the personal use of six
substances
psilocybin DMT ibogaine mescaline
excluding masculine from parody uh
ketamine MDMA and LSD so seven
um and there are a number of changes
that are made over the course of its
kind of traversing through the various
committees within the legislature and
the assembly and one of those changes
was eventually all of the synthetics
were taken out so the version that was
reintroduced this year just has DMT
psilocybin mescaline not from peyote and
ibogaine
so over the course of a couple years all
of the synthetics were eventually taken
out but ketamine was the first so
ketamine has a reputation
um although
I think that it's over indexed in law
enforcement world as a date rape drug
and uh along with GHB and rufinol
so and that's based on DEA data that I
did a lot of digging on and couldn't
find the source for but
not to say it doesn't happen I'm not
trying to diminish that I'm just like
there were a lot of claims that were
being made early on about ketamine
specifically
um and the argument and an argument was
made like whoa it's available legally so
why can't we just decriminalize it
um and the reasoning ultimately I think
boiled down to this idea that like white
powders are really scary and synthetics
are not something we can just create we
can just allow to be out there and even
with my like super anti-prohibitionist
frame there's some logic to that in the
sense that people are not that afraid of
growing cacti or mushrooms in their
backyard or in their closet but like
once you start to talk about synthetics
if you don't have like a safe Supply
like an actual Supply mechanism then
suddenly you have labs in residential
areas some of you may have seen there
was an explosion in San Francisco last
week that was a BHO lab in underground
um uh cannabis extraction lab that was
in the home
so people are really afraid of that and
it was interesting because one of the
issues that came up when I testified in
the California state legislature around
this bill was the question came up like
where did the drugs come from and we're
arguing the whole time we're like let us
pass safe Supply let us have a regulated
like Supply mechanism but that was past
the line that what people were going to
do so we could only decriminalize
personal use
um but that is the Paradox which is like
why can't we
get access to these things is because of
this kind of supply and manufacture
question so that's the reasoning it was
taken out but just to say a little bit
more about why I think it's a big
problem that it was taken out is that
first off one thing that I think a lot
of legislators and maybe law enforcement
aren't thinking of that's so intuitive
is that when you I believe that when we
if we were to decriminalize certain
substances you would actually reduce the
adulteration of those substances because
you would disincentivize cutting those
substances with a drug especially if the
other drug is still illegal so if you
decriminalize MDA Suddenly It's really
unlikely you get dma analogs on the
street because why would you sell a drug
that's still sort of illegal if you
could just sell the real thing
um of course that's like kind of basic
logic it doesn't always work that way in
the underground it's not quite so simple
but that was kind of like the the
reasoning and the direction
and ultimately uh the move toward
keeping it to just plant-based
substances uh was seen as being kind of
more viable as we see I saw in Colorado
so I think that will continue to be the
first wave is like where it's like
fairly plant oriented
um but I would like to see from a period
Public Health perspective white powders
also get decriminalized because those
are the ones that the most dangerous
hi you're talking about
um if it's legal why would people buy it
illegally well look at the Cannabis
Market oh absolutely this isn't the cost
of going to to a dispensary versus your
black market or why people still buy it
illegally and the other point I'd like
to make is you're talking about people
using it in a religious context or
growing it at home there's a large part
of the population that will never do
that and they're waiting for it to be
regulated of course so it can be used
in an improved medical way and of course
the pharmaceutical industry is all over
this there's a lot of private investment
going and of course there'll be a lot of
legislative battles because it's all
about the bucks right
so I think there's a lot going on in
that area absolutely and one thing I'll
add and this is that I didn't get the
chance to say what's good about
Healthcare
um earlier but but one interesting thing
is that if and when some of these
substances are incorporated into
Healthcare then at least for those that
have insurance may be able to take
advantage of the insurance systems that
exist to cover some of those those so
even in like Oregon and Colorado even if
we have legal regulated adult use
it's not impossible but right now it
seems highly unlikely that those
programs which are state legal but
federally illegal will be covered by
insurance so you're talking about like
you know two to five to seven thousand
dollars out of pocket
um
so it's a really good point and actually
that's actually just going back to your
question about Academy and also
um
ketamine is uh approved by The Who as an
essential medicine that means that it's
uh kind of part of like the UN basically
ensures that ketamine is available uh
because it's one of the most effective
pain medications opioids are really
expensive and most of the Globes is
ketamine as pain management it's about a
dollar eighty a dose in the generic so
the other thing is that when Jensen
Johnson Johnson came in and patented
sprovado as ketamine and then hiked it
up to 400 to 800 a dose they they were
they were basically like oh will
will take on the um kind of appropriate
use of ketamine and right now there is a
move to get generic ketamine the same
kind of
um approval through the FDA so that
suddenly so it's not just a single
patented molecule that's available for
the treatment of depression but actually
generic ketamine which like I said is
available literally everywhere
can I share a fun anecdote about
ketamine
okay it's related to this so in um the
nine no no not 90s mid-2000s
um ketamine as a recreational drug hit
China
and in the mid-2000s there was a really
big move from the Chinese government at
the UN level to move ketamine from
schedule three which is where it
currently is to schedule one at the U.N
level
um and without going into too much
background the UN treaties kind of
Define which we the U.S highly
influenced kind of Define the current
drug control scheme
um and there was a huge pushback from
our very own George Soros and the open
Society Foundation as well as a number
of countries throughout the world
to ensure that ketamines stayed in
schedule three because even though China
was really worried about the Chinese
government was really worried about the
recreational use of ketamine throughout
the country the fact that it's so needed
as an essential medicine the fact that
opioids are so expensive and essentially
unavailable in the global South meant
that they're needed to continue to be
some sort of pain management tool which
was ketamine so there was this big kind
of response and ketamine is still
schedule three it's still an essential
medicine but it's one of those things
where you really see The Clash of like
the criminalization framework and the
medical framework and the way that those
things overlap or don't
um
yeah and maybe the last thing sorry the
the reason we can have ads about
ketamine the reason you're getting those
ads is because when kovitz started
restrictions
um that existed on uh Healthcare to
require an in-person Healthcare
appointment before the prescription of
certain drugs were relaxed so for the
last few years you have a paradigm in
which Telehealth suddenly is an
acceptable front line and that just
meant that you've you've got like all of
the like erectile dysfunction drugs and
the anxiolytics and the amphetamines and
the academy like all of that stuff
suddenly became available to be
prescribed fully online that could
change there's a bunch of news you can
follow it around like whether or not
those Provisions will continue to exist
there's a lot of pushback in both
directions but that's why we have mail
order ketamine today whether or not the
continues is a big open question
um and I'll pause there I can talk more
about ketamine but
instead of right now
how can this policy go forward when
public opinion is that drug use is a
moral failing how's that going to be
fixed a lot of polling is happening to
start a lot of polling is happening
especially in the states where you're
seeing legislative legislation move
forward and this year I think that there
will be a dozen bills introduced there
may already be a dozen bills introduced
across the country
um so what's happening is you have
there's like the True Believers that
have been in it for a long time and now
literally in the last two years it went
from being like am I going to be a
legislator that sticks my neck out for
this issue to being like oh I can't be
the last one on this issue that happened
really fast so I would slightly push
back that is the public opinion of
public opinion but it's not actually so
true anymore
um partially because of the kind of the
again the desperation the need and of
course the narrative that I didn't even
go into it I won't do much today around
like veterans and PTSD and survivors of
sexual assault and like we need to help
people how do we help people so there is
actually this kind of which to me is a
little bit scary there's kind of a
pendulum swinging to like too much hype
um but you'd be surprised at how open
people are now because they're getting
so much they're hearing so much about
all of this hype and I feel like part of
our job at Maps is to like keep it like
yeah we're really excited too but
actually there's risks and we should
talk about those risks and we should
mitigate them by having crisis response
and education
um so yeah that's changed fast I'm not
saying that there's a lot of people who
still feel that way
um but I would say rapidly decreasing
now people are getting way too excited
um kind of wrap up in a sec
um do drugs come off schedule one
historically
um I love this question
um so
little drug policy under the moment
um there's this concept called a
bifurcated scheduling
it's one of those legal fictions so
right now
um drugs are on these different
schedules right control substance tax
Schedule one through five one being the
most restrictive five being the least
um do drugs come off of the schedule so
cannabis currently has three derivative
drugs that are all of that are legally
available
Marinol and epidiolex all of those are
cannabis derived
um cannabis
good old weed is still schedule one but
you're like wait a minute schedule one
requires that there's no medical use if
you have proven medical use how can I
stay in schedule one the government has
invented this concept called bifurcated
scheduling where the drug product which
is the term of our which refers to the
drug that's approved by the FDA which
includes the manufacturing framework the
Rems the risk evaluation and mitigation
strategy all the things that come with
the thing it goes down I mean it says
detail as like the color of the pills
what's on the package that is a drug
product
the drug product even if the molecule is
identical is scheduled separately so
you've got three drugs that are cannabis
derived at a non-schedule one while
cannabis is still in schedule one
and our current theory is that with with
MDMA and with psilocybin that really
working against this don't I'm not
endorsing this but it's very possible
that the uncontrolled version of those
drugs remains in schedule one while the
drug product gets placed in the schedule
other than schedule one
and the important the thing that's
important about that that's also
relevant is that scheduling and
criminalization are not always linked
criminalization is a multi-tiered thing
that's also highly influenced by the U.S
sentencing commission which is the
judicial Federal Judicial body that
basically sets norms for um sentencing
in the United States
um trickles down to the state level
so I like to remind people I appreciate
that kind of question like I like to
remind people that moving away from even
if we were to fully deschedule or
reschedule
um
that alone would not necessarily
eliminate criminalization that may take
more advocacy at the sentencing level at
the state level decriminate and so on
that so it'd be nice that would make
sense like oh it's like the higher up
than the worse or whatever but it's not
quite so simple but we are working
toward that and there is a big push to
actually fully deer reschedule it's I
think it's possible for example that
cannabis gets fully descheduled to taken
out of the control substance sector
that's pretty optimistic but it's not
it's not crazy whereas I think the other
drugs it'll be harder to take them off
but it may be possible if we have a more
sane policy to actually just kick them
out of schedule one at least
okay
um I think that sort of leads well into
the last question how do we you know
how do we make sure this legalization
and decriminalization process is
um accessible you know it doesn't just
benefit
um people who have access to resources
or who can navigate the insurance system
in the right way but actually has
effects on the prison system and you
know doesn't end up you know ends up
being sort of a fair distribution
so unlike the prohibition of heroin or
cocaine or Methamphetamine or even
cannabis where you have
a large identifiable population that's
been impacted by those criminalizations
but a lot of people in prison because of
those drugs basically
um
so you can really see the impact of the
current drug control scheme with respect
to people who use those drugs
psychedelics it's a little bit harder
because as I mentioned a lot of the
criminalization and the kind of cultural
context that
um allowed psychedelics to be
criminalized and repressed so early
meant that a lot of the the work that
had to get done by prohibition you could
say it was already it was already
happened my ancestors a lot of our you
know the my cultural history like the
use of psychedelics had been already
been repressed for 400 years by the time
Nixon came along you know
so I say that to say that um
one thing that we can do that we have
been pushing at the state level is
pairing any decriminalization with
expungement and with kind of the
elimination of Records but even if we
were to do that just looking at this
soberly the number of people who had
benefited by wiping records related to
psychedelics is still quite small not to
say that it's not important MDMA right
now is the of the psychedelics we can
argue whether or not MDM is but
um of the kind of classic psychos MDMA
is the one that's been the most heavily
enforced and those numbers are in like
the single digits or lower most of the
and they may be over you know we may
have may know more people who've been
impacted by that because of the world
that we may or not being but
overall the numbers fairly small so what
I like to say is I think that in
addition to decriminalization like real
decrim where you can have homegirl where
there's actually no mitigator between
you and the substance where you can just
grow it yourself
um I think that the other thing that I
like to do and my call to action
sometimes in conversations like this is
that for people that are interested in
psychedelic decriminalization or
psychedelic policy to actually bring
that energy to these other
um these other drugs and these issue
related to Other Drugs supervised
consumption sites medication assisted
treatment actual housing and care for
people who are addicted or dependent on
other drugs like that type of thing
people can say forever like once a drug
user always a drug User it's always the
same it's kind of like the point that
was been made earlier like well isn't it
just morally bad
I think that until all people who choose
to use drugs are able to be treated with
dignity we're just making gains on
something that could always be pulled
out from under our feet so I do think
that moving toward that really broad
vision for post prohibition World
um that actually has access to health
care and support and housing and
environmental justice and all the other
things that we really want to see I
think that like I like to say like pivot
that energy that's about that's focused
on psychedelics and that comes out of
that personal growth into these other
places where we can bring Justice
because to me if we don't you know if
we're not all free and working together
to eradicate the stigma then like it can
always be turned against us in the long
run so I see that as like we're all part
of this together like you can think of
yourself as different from someone who's
using Benton on the street but the
government doesn't so we got to work for
all of us if we're trying to do anything
at all all right thank you so much
[Applause]
um
and thank you everyone we're going to
reset the room which means standing up
and grabbing your glass and then sort of
like moving away while we stack all the
chairs back up but um please stay for a
little while have a drink we'll be here
for a while thanks
[Applause]
[Music]